conseillers départementaux régionaux ou
encore municipaux de nombreux élus de la
droite et du centre étaient rassemblés
ce samedi 22 janvier une soirée pour
lancer le comité de soutien de valérie
pécresse dans les yvelines pour la
présidentielle 2022 des élus locaux
essentiel dans la stratégie de campagne
de la candidate
ça va être à eux aussi d'aller à la
rencontre des citoyens c'est donc
d'abord une campagne de rencontres une
campagne des changes campagne où on
montre on écoute les français on essaie
de répondre à leurs problèmes et francis
ont besoin d'être entendus parmi les
acteurs de la campagne nicole pompidou
la belle fille de georges pompidou
deuxième président de la vème république
elle a en charge les relations avec la
société civile dans le département pour
soutenir valérie pécresse c'est une
femme
courageuse attentes intègre
et c'est une femme comme je le disais de
coeur elle aime la france et elle aime
les français c'est la filiation c'est
gaulle pompidou chirac et valéry présent
aussi l'union des démocrates
indépendants des yvelines des centristes
qui soutiennent la candidate et l'air en
prenant leur distance avec emmanuel
macron et la république en marche ce qui
nous vraiment nous séparent de de l'amac
redit j'allais dire c'est cet
exercice du pouvoir vertical et là c'est
quelque chose d'absolument
rédhibitoire lui d un allié historique
de la droite yvelinoise aujourd'hui ils
sont présents dans plusieurs majorités
deux élus régionaux quatre élus
départementaux et de nombreux élus
municipaux